michael smith a brother from another
right here on the rich eisen show on nbc
sports on peacock would you go into
space michael do you going to speak hell
no
[Laughter]
i barely like amusement park rides my
nerves too bad for that for space no i
know i don't like roller coasters either
i don't like the drops or whatever but
just to go through it for what
for what to see that you've been in
outer space to see
thank you michael an angle of the world
that you've never seen before that huge
few humans have done the world yeah
you've seen the whole world already you
been around the planet no i'd like to
well plus though i just want to make
sure that i i could at least take a
photograph and prove to kyrie the world
is not flat at least i could do that i
want i want to see earth not earth i
won't see earth first
work on this planet first no thank you
i'm good i'll live vicariously through
the movies through william shatner and
everybody else but no i'm straight on
space though but thanks for asking
you're welcome you're welcome michael
smith here from uh brother from another
here on peacock right here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line on the
rich eisen show okay let's get into it
um
what's uh what's your take on
what we heard from um shams at the
athletic as to the reason why um
kyrie irving might miss the entire
season for the nets
um it's on brand i'll start with that um
some people are just on some other ish
and kyrie is one of those people
and a lot of times i do respect it
but there are things to him that are
bigger than basketball i guess and
listen this does not need my approval
but i do have an opinion on it and i
guess i'm better with this reported
explanation
than i am the conspiracy theory aspect
of it
um at least he's not
anti-science
based on his explanation
he's trying to be a quote-unquote voice
for the voiceless which i would take
exception to that because
the unvaccinated population is anything
but voiceless
matter of fact
the very loud
in many cases loud and wrong if i may
say so but nonetheless
you know
they're well spoken for so i don't think
kyrie irving uh i don't think the
unvaccinated need kyrie irving to be
some sort of professional
martyr for them but if that's his choice
i'm actually prepared to take my cue
from sean marks in the nets and move on
i love that they made their choice same
as he made
his
and they were like over trying to
compromise and work around it because
they definitely have enough to still win
the championship they're not
overwhelming favorites but as far as
they're concerned it should be no
different than a player missing a season
because of injury and they certainly got
a lot of experience playing without one
of their big three
uh last year due to injuries
they
added to their lineup in the offseason
so
listen kyrie gonna do kyrie and kyrie as
we know is not about to be peer
pressured
or reasoned with when he's got his mind
made up on something that's who he is
that comes with the package
good for him do you
michael smith here on the rich eisen
show um yeah i i had a similar
approach that uh i i take a
you know um
a little bit of disagreement and calling
well a lot of disagreement and that the
people who are unvaccinated is voiceless
uh yeah i was pointing out that there's
a three-hour block on the most watched
cable network on uh television in the
united states america talking about
vaccine mandates in the manner that
kyrie irving would agree with apparently
i would argue that they might even have
louder voices given the position right
that some of those voices occupy in our
country right and i've seen videos of uh
anti-vaxxers overturning covet testing
sites tables on the streets of america
i've seen
you know actually disruptive behavior
that shows up on my timeline on my phone
but you're right like maybe you should
take the cue and we should all for sean
marks if like that's your decision we're
moving on we'll chat with you if you
have your change of opinion and we'll
pay attention to the matter you know
they all come and go
all of us are temporary
you know i mean the show goes on
we all we all know that in this business
and every other business and every other
walk of life so the nba is going to have
a great 75 75th season and the nets are
gonna be great weather without kyrie so
this is what he wants to do this is
important to him
godspeed michael smith the brother from
another right here on the rich eisen
show we are taking you to his show with
michael holly at the top of the hour is
our show precedes theirs every single
day on the nbc sports on peacock
lineup how did john gruden's resignation
hit you michael
um how did it hit me i like how you
phrased that
um
well let's start with the obvious that
uh when he was merely
uh behaving like a racist
um i don't mean laughter
for him to remain as raiders coach as
evident by the fact that he coached on
sunday
and mark davis and moore
uh knew about those emails for quite a
while
before
the new york times report
uh in which he was exposed as behaving
in a homophobic
sexist misogynistic
so on and so on manner
um
that he just couldn't survive it
um
it seems like we've reached something of
a dead end
uh i'm not holding my breath as i take a
deep breath and i hold my breath that
the nfl is going to
be transparent given that
confidentiality was promised on the
front end of the football team
investigation
and i think uh what we've seen
with gruden and now
uh prominent media members practices
uh coming out in the wash that there's
just too much here
both both legally
and
uh in terms of
learning how the sausage is actually
made
uh when it comes to this product here uh
there's just too much here at stake for
the league to actually release
these 650 000 emails and the rest of the
findings of this quote-unquote
investigation
um and i say quote-unquote investigation
i don't even know that it was actually
legitimate i know they find it snyder 10
million dollars but you're not going to
tell me that the most salacious and the
most egregious and the most unethical
thing to come out of an investigation
into dan schneider's organization is
john gruden's emails or for that matter
adam schefter's
like there's a lot of skeletons in this
here closet forget racist bones are full
on skeletons
in this hair closet and for what i
understand
this rabbit hole not only goes deep and
wide but it goes high
now i haven't seen some emails myself so
i wouldn't dare
you know report this or name names but
my understanding is that there are
people
in the nfl office
that are
uh
pulled into this and whose addresses and
whose emails are
quite questionable that if that got out
that's a whole nother set of problems
so
gruden was not even the tip of the
iceberg group group was a drop in the
bucket i've said the last few days this
is the largest societal issue
about how people like john gruden speak
in private and it's not just that they
have these opinions
um that are that run counter and
detrimental to societal progress and in
general and nfl inclusivity in
particular
what the problem is how these beliefs
manifest themselves in their actions and
i'm going to talk about john gruden and
his and his personnel decisions or his
coaching decisions i'm talking about
ceos
and
uh you know business owners politicians
these are these are beliefs that are
widely held they just aren't typically
said out loud or in writing
and
there's a lot of these people a lot of
people saying the same types of things
still in 2021 as antiquated as it may
sound to some
far from it
and my fear is that while gruden
uh took the fall for this investigation
and while gruden is getting all the
attention there are still people that
are walking
talking and acting in and on these same
beliefs about women about black people
about the lgbtq community
every day
and
it's going to take a long time before
this system
and and the people that perpetuate this
system are actually smoked out john gru
again john gruden's will come and go uh
racism i don't know how much you guys
you know watch the agenda the avengers
excuse me
you know racist it's like racist sexist
misogynist homophobes it's like hydra
man cut off one head two pop up in his
place you know so
um i'm i'm not moved by john gruden's
firing or his removal from the bucks
ring of honor because i know that the
world's gonna keep spinning it's a dirty
world and we just got to figure out a
way to kind of keep living in it well
what do you say michael smith to those
that you know you know i've i've read
the tweets as well and i'd love to have
you be the one to uh give me your
thoughts are you ready sweets what i'll
like it up for a second i've read the
tweets um uh on my twitter account we
haven't really discussed it much here
and i figured i'll i'll have you um you
know take the floor on it that uh
gruden's out but uh there are those you
know they they there are those who are
going culture warrior that the nfl is
having people who have used offensive
lyrics be the the
the primary um
the primary uh uh entertainment
of the super bowl and others who have uh
broken the law actually run afoul of the
law given second chances to actually
participate in the nfl and gruden is the
one who is canceled
what do you say to that
well i'll just and i know you aren't
using this i'll just no i'm i'm i'm
trust me i i was talking about how
yesterday uh you know the social uh
media culture warriors in our profession
uh it's a great day for them for clicks
but yesterday was a great day for those
who believe words matter and also public
health trumps all because you know kyrie
uh and the nets um that was resolved in
that manner yesterday so it was a great
day for a lot of people
yesterday that's what i was yeah just
the word cancel and and the buzzword of
the day cancel culture um
[Music]
for accountability
uh for growth and evolution and
you know that's yeah i'm all for cancer
culture let's let's cancel
racism let's cancel sexism let's cancel
misogyny
it's just it's a false equivalency that
i i even hate to have to
lower myself to address well i know what
you can move on if you want i i just
thought you know i don't want to you
know if you don't want to if i don't
mind i don't know i don't mind no i'm
not that's not i don't mind i'm saying
because i know it's out there but the
part about the rap lyrics in particular
like the same people always that that's
like that's at the top of the playbook
it's like oh let's talk about rap music
like that's entertainment
you know and i'm not saying that
entertainment doesn't matter but that's
completely different than somebody in a
position of power
and authority
and influence
uh espousing the views that john gruden
did not to mention i mean look let's
just call it what it is doing at the
commissioner sideways
i mean come on now and at the end of the
day he was bad for business
like i've always been hesitant rich
don't get me wrong i've always been
hesitant when it comes to legislating
morality or even when it comes to
conversations about well
what's the right amount of gains on the
personal conduct policy that this guy
should get for hitting a woman versus
this guy
should get for
an accusation of sexual assault versus
this guy should get for deflating
football it's like
it has certainly not comparing those two
things i'm saying there's always
you know there's there's never a perfect
answer into what punishment should fit
the so-called crime
so it is a slippery slope for sure to
take
uh john gruden out of the bucks ring of
honor
while warren sapp for example remains
and antonio brown is still playing
um
it's business it's optics it's pr and
and and i do agree i do agree
that if we were to open everybody's
proverbial closet
there'd be a lot of people taking on a
lot of halls of fans and rings of honor
removed from their positions
but that's not what's happening here
what happened here is that over seven
years
john gruden
made some statements that are
unacceptable and they're bad for
business and they tarnish the shield
now the real question is if john gruden
won what 12 games under five hundred
whatever he is
the real question is if john grew more
successful
would
mark davis had made that same move would
he have still had no choice
or was it rather convenient
he certainly seemed to want to keep him
like i said when he was just the racist
um
but no i listen i get it
i get it but that's
we can't
get distracted from the issue at hand
and say well if we're going to hold john
gruden accountable let's hold let's
let's not have rap music at halftime
like that's not the same thing and if we
got to explain why it's not the same
thing i just kind of question the
motivation the people that's trying to
draw that false equivalency so no i was
happy to answer the question i'm just
saying like
you kind of just know it's always the
same types of people
there's a venn diagram when it comes to
the rest of their views
on society in general that go quick go
straight to the go straight to the what
about ism playbook you know what i mean
i do well who's on your show
who's on your rundown i assume these two
items that we just mentioned here it's
kind of a preview
okay but any time
seriously you call me you just let me
know you have my numbers you know how to
reach me
i got i got i got your digits i got your
math uh mark j spears from the
undefeated joining us today our boy
jason johnson's coming through today
from msnbc mike jones
from the washington post who spoke to
demora smith is coming through okay
great um and door's always open uh we'll
leave the light on for you um you know
what i know where the key is um anytime
always just fall through if you feel
like it same for you as you know thanks
for the call michael appreciate it there
you go there you go kirk
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here